denise clark county moving forward with
the trial run of paying people a hundred
dollars to get the vaccine right now
just under half of the eligible
population is fully vaccinated joe
mohler is live at the vaccine clinic at
unlv stan fulton building with
information on this particular incentive
joe
yeah this site here usually operates
five days a week but it's actually
closed this evening it's already set up
for it but it'll be back open on sunday
we've been seeing a number of folks come
by here wondering if they can get their
tests for their vaccine but this site is
closed but county commissioners are now
looking forward they're trying to figure
out how they can get more people
vaccinated and they think maybe offering
an incentive such as 100 bucks might
help
i do not believe it's going to make a
difference will one hundred dollars push
more people to get their shot that is
what county commissioners want to find
out some don't think it is enough a
hundred dollars
people spend that just eating out one
night people
are resisting and i don't even think
money will make a difference regardless
clark county commissioners want to give
this idea a shot the key is to see if it
works this is just a pilot program but
if based on what other happens in other
cities it will work commissioner tick
zigger blum brought the idea forward
they plan to pick one weekend in
september to give this a run he says
other cities have had success minnesota
the numbers went up several hundred
percent
new york city did fifty thousand
club was ohio colorado springs it's all
around the country everywhere it's been
tried it really increased turnout now
the money is coming from the county's
440 million dollars of american relief
funds there will be one hundred dollars
for one thousand people who get their
doses that weekend siggerblum hopes the
state will help with the efforts i'm
hoping that the governor will step up
and maybe match our 100 thousand dollars
and then going forward
if it works let's do it sigerblum says
they want to focus on areas where
vaccination rates are lower some believe
those who want to get the vaccine will
get it without an incentive everybody is
so polarized right now i really think
that
it won't matter
back out here live this incentive
program will have a trial run next month
the location and dates have not been
announced just yet but they do if they
do have success with it they do hope to
do it once again in the future but again
this unlv stanfolten site for the
testing and vaccination is closed this
evening and it will be open again on
sunday reporting live at unlv this
evening joe muller 8 news now